- I mean, think about it.
We just celebrated Martin
Luther King's birthday,
a man who is associated
with colorblindness.
"Judge me by the
content of my character,
not the color of my skin."
That is what the Civil Rights
Movement used to be about.
Today, the Civil Rights Movement
is about Black Lives Matter.
Not all lives
(laughs), black lives,
say it, or I'm coming after you.
We've turned the King
sensibility on its head.
I mean, that's where
we are as a country.
And that's what the
left is as a country.
And I don't think that Joe Biden
feels he can oppose that
and succeed politically
in the Democratic Party.
So I think he's doing what
he feels he needs to do.
He needed a black woman
as a running mate.
So he found a
black woman to run.
And I think he's checking off
the boxes in terms of race
and gender and
sexual orientation,
right down the list,
because that is what
today's left demands.
(bright music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a senior fellow at
the Manhattan Institute,
a Wall Street Journal columnist
and author of the upcoming book,
"Maverick: A Biography
of Thomas Sowell."
Jason Riley, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Thanks for having me.
- I am glad to have you here.
I thought this would be the
right week to have you on,
not only because the
doc is coming out,
but obviously
Monday was MLK Day.
There's a lot going
on in the world,
and I've been
following what you do
and what the Manhattan Institute
does for quite some time.
So I'm looking
forward to the chat.
For the people that don't
have any idea who you are,
who is Jason Riley and why
is he on "The Rubin Report?"
- (laughs) Well,
I'm a journalist.
I've been affiliated with
the Wall Street Journal
for about a quarter century now.
And I write a political column
for them, a weekly column,
mostly about urban issues.
Crime, immigration, race,
economics, and so forth.
And I'm also, like you, a
big fan of Thomas Sowell.
And I've written a few
books over the years.
And my most recent one is a
biography of Thomas Sowell,
which is being published
right around the same time
that a documentary
film on his life
that I narrate is
also being released.
- Yeah, so the book is coming
out actually on May 25th,
and we'll put the
pre-order link below.
The doc is actually
coming out this weekend
on some public TV stations
and then streaming services
and all that good stuff.
And obviously, you know,
I know that you know
how much Thomas Sowell
has affected me,
and I'm actually honored
to be in the doc.
And you use some of the
footage from our interview
that we did up at Stanford.
But, you know, you
just hit on a bunch
of the hot topics of the day.
And as we're taping this today,
it is Joe Biden's inauguration,
but you mentioned,
you talk about
crime, immigration,
urban issues, things like that.
And as a Wall
Street Journal guy,
my audience can
probably put together
that lean somewhat right.
Are you hopeful?
Are you worried?
What do you feel
about the incoming
administration right now
on the issues that
you care about?
- Well, I care about
how divided we are as
a country right now.
And I'm hoping that Joe Biden
can lower the
volume a little bit.
I think that's gotten
way out of hand
as we saw as what happened
at the at the Capitol
there earlier this month.
So I'm hoping that
that's a priority of his,
and maybe he'll be
able to do that.
He's, I'm encouraged
by some of the things
he's done so far.
Some of his cabinet picks, I
think, have been quite moderate
in comparison to what
we could have had.
We don't have, you know, a
Secretary Warren at Treasury,
or a Secretary Bernie Sanders
running the labor department.
So I am hopeful there
with some of his
choices that he's made.
On the other hand, you
know, I'm quite disturbed
at the direction of the
Democratic Party in recent years
with the rise of
the progressives,
you know, the sort of
woke left disturbs me,
the Black Lives Matter
movement types disturb me.
And the fact of the
matter is that Joe Biden
is the head of a party that's
moved quite a bit to the left
since the last time he
was in the White House.
And while he's a
guy who I think is,
spent a career trying
to find the center
of the Democratic Party
and stay right there,
the fact is the party
itself has moved left.
And so I think we're, I fear
we're going to get a lot more
of the identity politics that
we had under president Obama,
and that worries me
because he left office
with race relations in
pretty, pretty bad shape.
I think they continued to
sour under President Trump,
but they were already pretty
bad when Trump got into office
as a result of what
happened under Obama.
And I'm fearful that Biden
and his adherence to identity
politics and so forth
will keep us going in that
direction, unfortunately.
- Yeah, are you
kind of surprised
how much Biden has
embraced identity politics?
Because as you're pointing
out, he's not actually,
we think, or at
least his history
is not one of the sort of
really far left, you know,
the Bernie Elizabeth Warren's,
it is more of a centrist,
but it's pretty
clear that, you know,
he's saying, "Okay, well,
we got Pete Buttigieg,
so we have a gay
transportation secretary
and we got a trans, I think,
assistant health secretary
or deputy health secretary."
Nobody cares if you have
gay people or trans people
and black people and all of
these things, that's wonderful,
but of course you
want qualification.
Are you surprised he's doing,
or do you think he's just
doing a certain amount
of placating them to then
get back to the center?
That would be music to my ears,
but I fear that energy
that you're talking about.
- Yeah, I think he
feels he has to do it,
that this is where the party is.
and if anything, it's
gotten worse in recent years
with, I mean, think about it.
We just celebrated Martin
Luther King's birthday,
a man who was associated
with colorblindness.
"Judge me by the
content of my character,
not the color of my skin."
That is what the
Civil Rights Movement
used to be about.
Today, the Civil Rights Movement
is about Black Lives Matter.
Not all lives
(laughs), black lives.
Say it, or I'm coming after you.
It we've turned the King
sensibility on its head.
I mean, that's where
we are as a country.
And that's what the
left is as a country.
And I don't think that Joe
Biden feels he can oppose that
and succeed politically
in the Democratic Party.
So I think he's doing what
he feels he needs to do.
He needed a black woman
as a running mate.
So he found a
black woman to run.
And I think he's checking off
the boxes in terms of race
and gender and
sexual orientation,
right down the list,
because that is what
today's left demands.
- That's, it's very bizarre.
I've asked this of
a few other people
that I've had on the show,
but are you shocked at the
way these seemingly bad ideas
have taken a hold of so
many of our institutions
and our political elite and
our our media institutions
and everything else?
- I am, I'm quite concerned.
and there's so little pushback.
There's the, even on the left,
they're canceling each other.
If you don't toe the
line on uncertain issues,
everyone from a Steven Pinker
or to an Andrew Sullivan to,
you are not allowed to step
out of line over there,
or the mob will come after you.
And I find it
extremely disturbing.
I don't think that it's helpful
in terms of addressing
real issues in society.
It keeps us at each
other's throat,
but this is how the
Democratic Party wins votes.
This is how they
drum up their base.
And what we're going
through right now
with the critical race theory.
I mean, I'm old enough to
remember when this stuff started
back in the '70s and
'80s, in particular,
but it was sort of
limited to academia.
And now it's spilled
over into the mainstream,
and we're talking about,
you know, unconscious bias
and these ridiculous
diversity training programs
and demanding the
self-abasement of whites
and to acknowledge their
privilege and all the rest.
This is, I think this is
horrible for the country.
Just absolutely horrible.
And I think all of
that will be ascended
in a Joe Biden
presidency, unfortunately.
- Yeah, I'm with you.
And unfortunately is
the key word there.
So you mentioned just
sort of generally
the state of race relations
that they got worse under Obama.
You feel they got
worse under Trump.
And now here we are
with this new ideology
that seemingly will
only make it worse.
When you say got worse, what,
how do you actually define that?
Because I find when I,
the limited amount that I've
traveled in the last year
because of COVID, but from
talking to my audience
and hearing what
people are saying
and when I do get to travel,
I think most people don't
really care about race.
I don't think people really
care about sexuality.
I certainly don't think
they care about gender.
I think Americans, probably
something like 80% of them
are kind of live and let live.
They just don't know it exactly.
It's not the messaging they get.
How do you actually
grade sort of, okay,
it got worse under Obama or
it got worse under Trump?
- Well, I'm basing
that on polling data.
Gallup Poll ask this
question every few years.
Do you think race relations
have improved or worsened?
And when Obama left
office in 2015,
or 2016, I should say,
that poll answer showed
that race relations
were at their lowest point
since the early '90s.
So they had really,
really tapered off,
and then they didn't
improve much under Trump,
at least in terms of how
people were responding
to that question.
Now, there could be something
in the way the question
is asked frame or something,
and maybe anecdotally, it's
easy to counter that notion.
I mean, if, you know,
intermarriage rates are up,
(laughs) you know, if things
like that are going on
if there's less segregation
in residential
housing and so forth,
that would all point in
the opposite direction.
So it may be a way of how
the question is framed,
but I'm basing it
on the polling,
the polling data that I've read.
- Yeah, and then
at the same time,
we see interesting things.
Like, I think, it was
black female support,
I think, doubled for Trump
than four years prior,
we saw the Brexit movement.
We did see some markers that
things are kind of changing,
but I sense now it
could all be for not.
- I think we saw
some indications that
there's no reason
for the Republican Party to
give up on the minority vote.
Trump improved his
performance among blacks,
and especially among
Hispanic voters.
And I think that had a
lot to do with his focus
on reopening the
economy after COVID.
People forget how bad
things were particularly
for black men under Obama
in terms of employment.
The black unemployment rate did
not fall below double digits
until the seventh year
of the Obama presidency.
So things were very bad
for a very long time.
And then under Trump, we see
record low unemployment rates,
record low poverty rates.
We see the wages rising for
the least skilled workers
at the fastest rate
of all workers.
Things were going
quite well pre-COVID
in terms of the economy,
and COVID really
shut all that down.
And I think Trump's
focus on reopening
and getting people back to work
is one reason he improved
his numbers among minorities.
- Yeah, so before we
jump into to the doc
and Thomas Sowell and all that,
let's do a little bit
the right side of things.
I think a lot of people
that are watching this
probably agreeing
with your assessment
of what's going on on the left.
What do you make of what's
going on on the right right now?
Like do you think Trump
is gonna lead some sort
of Patriot Party now?
What happens to
establishment Republicans?
Can they reconcile
all of this stuff?
- Well, who knows what
Donald Trump is gonna do?
(laughs) I mean.
- Indeed, indeed.
- I've stopped trying to
guess about his intentions.
It may be limited
in what he can do,
depending on how this
impeachment process plays out.
I guess Mitch McConnell
has made some comments
that lead some to believe that
he would vote for conviction.
And others say that if he
does, others will follow suit.
And if the Senate
convicts him in a way
that prevents him from
running for office again,
then that could quash
efforts going forward.
I guess he could
still have influence
in terms of endorsing
people or so forth
or funding movements, but
in terms of personally,
and his own political career,
that could probably be the the
nail in the coffin on that.
- Yeah, it does
seem like, you know,
the quote-unquote swamp
is sort of ready to just
circle and expunge him,
but what do you do with
those 74 million people?
I guess that's
really the question.
- Well, yeah. He's,
got his followers.
We don't know what
will happen with them.
Some of them were people
that were not politically
active at all.
He made them come out
and participate in politics
for the first time.
So could they go back
to being inactive again?
Some of them, a lot of them,
and the left doesn't
like to acknowledge this,
but a lot of them were
former Obama voters
that he won in 2016.
- Me!
- And held onto in 2020.
- Yeah.
- So what will become
of those voters without Trump?
But, you know, yes.
You know, the Republican Party
is worried about losing
some of those Trump voters,
but I also think,
and I don't know how they
compare in terms of numbers,
but I can say there are also
a fair number of Republicans
like my wife, for instance,
who could never bring herself
to support Donald Trump.
She didn't like the way
he talked about women
or demean the war record of
military heroes and so forth.
So she did not support
Republicans while
he was in office,
but she's perfectly
ready to go back
to supporting Republican
presidential candidates now.
So I don't know how
representative she is
of people out there.
So who knows how
this will play out.
But I think it's
clear that the country
may have been tired
of Donald Trump,
but they voted for
divided government.
They shrunk the Democrats
lead in the House.
We have a 50/50 Senate.
So the country is not
throwing out republicanism
with Donald Trump.
And I think that's something
Biden should keep in mind
as he goes forward governing.
- Yeah, I mean, in
my humble opinion,
if he goes down the
identity politics route
that it seems like
he's going down,
they're going to get crushed
even harder in two years,
which probably would be good
to balance things out, but.
- Well, I think, you know,
Obama made this mistake
when he came into office,
and maybe Joe Biden
learned from it,
but I think they
saw George W. Bush
with very low approval
ratings going out of office.
And they interpreted
that as a mandate
for a far left agenda.
So they passed the
stimulus package.
They didn't do much.
And then they turned their
attention to reforming,
transforming the healthcare
system in this country
in a highly partisan fashion.
And it turned out to
be hugely unpopular.
They lost in time both
houses of Congress,
the Democrats did, and it
turned out to be a disaster.
And it'll be interesting to know
if Biden interprets
Trump's unpopularity
with a mandate for
moving forward with
a progressive agenda.
I don't think people voted for
him for a progressive agenda.
So we'll see if Joe
Biden learned anything
from the last time he
was in the White House.
- Yeah, that I guess
is the tension.
It's like, yeah, he wants to,
or maybe in the past, would
have been more center.
The energy's over here,
and just sort of how far
can that push and pull go.
All right.
So let's talk about the
doc and Thomas Sowell.
First off,
when did you become aware of
the work of Thomas Sowell?
How did this whole
project come together?
- Oh, well, I first became
aware of Thomas Sowell
when I was in college
in the early 1990s.
I was having some, where I
worked in my college paper,
and I was having a conversation
about Affirmative Action
with one of my colleagues
on the school paper.
And another person
walked over and said,
"You sound like Tom Sowell."
And I said, "Tom, who?"
And I had no idea who he was.
Person wrote down
the name of a book.
I went and checked it out of
school library that evening
and read it in one sitting
and spent the weekend
reading everything else
that the library had
by Thomas Sowell.
And I was hooked.
And so he really
had a big impact
on my sort of intellectual
development since college,
but I was already
leaning more conservative
by the time I discovered Thomas,
which is, I found out later,
is not at all uncommon.
I mean, by the time
Clarence Thomas
discovered Thomas
Sowell, his reaction was,
"Wow, there's someone else
out there who thinks like me."
Walter Williams who
recently passed away
had the exact same experience.
They were friends for 50 years.
And, but by, when
they first met,
Walter Williams was already
Walter Williams (laughs).
So you hear this time and again,
people have found their
way to Thomas Sowell,
but he hasn't necessarily
led them to believe
what they now believe.
- Right, so as a guy that
writing a book about him,
or wrote a book about
him that's upcoming
and did the doc and everything,
you must be just
like over the moon
that he's had this resurgence,
this renaissance
with young people.
Because when I
interviewed him, I mean,
the amount of
emails that we got,
and handwritten letters
and Facebook messages
and the whole thing, saying
this man transformed my life.
And in many ways for me, you
know, people always say to me,
"Dave, it seems like you've
changed so much politically."
And I always say, "Well,
actually, mostly the same.
Economics is where I changed.
It's just, that's the one,
like I don't deny it," right?
But the other stuff
is pretty much there
and was always there.
But economics is the
one that really changed.
And it was because
of Thomas Sowell.
It was happening
before that interview.
But to me that
moment, that was it,
that pretty much was it.
- And I am thrilled that a
younger generation of people
are interested in Sowell
because what he is writing,
written over the years is
as relevant today as ever.
He was writing about
social justice issues
30 and 40 years ago.
And he's still right
about these things.
In fact, it is amazing how long
he has been so right
about so many issues.
You can go back and
read personal letters
that he wrote in
the 1960s to people
about how he thought the
Civil Tights Movement
was going to end.
It's really, really amazing how,
his prescience in that regard,
but so in terms of me
personally discovering Sowell,
that's what had happened
back in college.
In terms of the film.
Well, I guess I should
start with a book.
I've been, I've known Sowell
for about 15, 20 years,
and I've been pressuring him
to let me do this
biography for some time.
And I knew I could
do it without him.
He said I could
do it without him,
but I wanted his cooperation.
I didn't think a lot of
other people would talk to me
if they, if I didn't have
his blessing to do it.
And he finally gave in and let
me start restart writing it.
So I started on it
about five years ago.
Four years ago, I got
interrupted by someone else
to write another book
about another issue.
So I put the Sowell book aside,
and then I got back
to it about 2018.
And the results will be
out in the in the spring.
When the people at the
Free To Choose network,
and they're the ones who
produce the documentary,
learned about the book,
they came to me and asked me
if I would be interested in
narrating a documentary film
that they were putting together.
And Sowell had a long history
with the Free To Choose network
through Milton Friedman,
one of his mentors who did
a series for Free To Choose
on public television
back in the early 1980s,
and Sowell was, participated
in Milton Friedman's show.
And so they wanted to do
a documentary on Sowell.
They asked me if I was
interested in being a narrator
and helping and
developing the film.
And that's how that got started.
- Yeah, there's a moment.
I think when I was interviewed,
I mentioned this moment.
I don't know if it
made it into the doc,
but I'm sure you'll
appreciate this.
When I finished the
interview with him,
and I had tweeted out
right before, you know,
I'm about to sit down
with Thomas Sowell.
You know, if he's
influenced you in any way,
send me a message.
And maybe I can read
a couple to him.
And I got, I mean,
I got hundreds if not
thousands of tweets.
And I said to him
at the end, I said,
"Dr. Sowell, I tweeted
out that, you know,
I'm sitting down with you,
and I just got so many
of these great messages.
If you want to take a look."
And I kind of
showed him my phone,
and he goes with that
great voice, he goes,
"Young man, I've been doing
this for a long time."
And I just thought it
was the perfect response.
Like truly the perfect response.
Getting to what you're saying,
that the things that he was
talking about 30, 40 years ago,
they're relevant and
feel new to us now.
But this has been a
long slog for this guy.
- Oh yeah. Yeah, it has been.
And there's a, lot of people
think that Tom is on Twitter
because there is a fan site,
and it's run by a millennial
who has never met Tom.
It's not an authorized side.
And all this guy
does is tweet quotes
from past Sowell
columns and books.
That's it, there's no
added commentary to them.
He just takes these quotes
and tweets them out.
It has hundreds of
thousands of followers,
which would be
amazing for anyone,
but especially for someone
who's not on social media.
(laughs) like Thomas Sowell is.
- Yeah. No, it
really, that account.
I mean, it's at Thomas Sowell.
And for a long time,
I thought it was some
sort of official account,
but every time they tweet
out a meme or just a quote,
whatever it is, and it's like
if he wrote that yesterday,
you'd be going, "Man,
this guy knows what's up."
And then of course you find
out, oh, no, he wrote that,
you know, in 1969 or
something like that.
- Well, people are,
what's amazing.
And this speaks to your comment
about how long Sowell
has been doing this.
He, you know, people often say
to me after I give a speech
or write something in the paper,
"Oh, you know, he
must be very brave
to write something like that."
You know, and it's
really easily,
if I write something
contrarian about race
or an issue like that.
And I don't think
there's anything
particularly brave about it.
I think of Sowell as someone
who's particularly brave.
I mean, he's been doing
this for a long time.
Well, before there
was a Fox News.
Well before there was
social media support
or talk radio people
that had his back
and that sort of thing.
He was just out there
writing this stuff,
and he was doing
it largely alone.
And without the support
that many conservatives,
particularly black
conservatives today have.
So that's bravery
in my book (laughs).
- What kind of support
do you think black
conservatives have now?
Because I think you could
probably argue it both ways.
On one hand, there is now some
defensive black conservatives
that I have many black
conservative friends.
There's more out
there obviously,
but on the other hand,
I'm not going to
have to tell you
all the things that
you guys get called.
And I don't even
want to say them
because YouTube will
delete the video.
- That comes with the territory.
Yes. The name calling
has always been there.
But there's far more support.
I mean, I'll put it this
way. The way Tom has put it.
Back in the 1980s, Thomas
Sowell and Walter Williams
made a pact never
to fly together.
Because if the plane went down,
it'd be the end of black
conservatism in America.
So we're a long way from
that today, you know?
And just the support I get.
I, you know, I was
a few years ago,
I was invited to speak
at a college campus,
and then I was
dis-invited to speak.
I wrote a column about it.
I went on television
and talked about it.
The president of the
university was bombarded
with complaints from graduates
and and even some students
at the school for
dis-inviting me.
They reversed course (laughs)
and re-invited me.
That sort of thing.
I don't know that Tom
would have ever had
that kind of support
30 or 40 years ago,
but that's what's out there
today for black conservatives.
Yeah.
- Do you find that
his evolution,
as I talked to him about it
and we had this great viral
clip where I said, you know,
"How did your political
evolution happen?"
And, you know, he
just paused, "Facts."
You know, it's just facts.
That was what caused him
to go from, you know,
a Marxist in essence
to a libertarian.
It seems like it's happening
to an awful lot of
people right now.
It's not something that the
media is going to talk about,
but it seems like a lot of
young people are getting it.
- I, maybe.
Maybe we talked to different
young people (laughs).
- No, a lot of them
are missing it too.
I know that.
- When I see them the rise.
When I see the rise of an
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
the way she talks about
how their should, you know,
billionaires should be banned,
or that sort of thing tells me
something else
might be going on.
and I think, you know,
part of it might have to
do with the experience.
I mean, if you're a
young person today,
and your idea of how, you know,
an economy should be growing
or what the employment should
look like in this country,
was the Obama years,
or shortly thereafter,
you know, that's
your experience.
And maybe you're
thinking capitalism
isn't all that great of a thing.
If this is, you
know, all it can do.
So maybe you have a skewed
sense of capitalism,
and maybe that's where
people like AOC come from
in terms of how they view
free market economics.
But I think that Republicans
and conservative
intellectuals in general,
I think need to do a better job
of communicating these
ideas to young people.
I think, in a large
sense, they're losing.
They're losing that fight.
Now the young people typically
are more left of center,
as Tom was when he was younger.
And then they grow up,
they grow out of it.
Experience teaches them
that another way is better.
But I do think that
Republicans in particular
need to do a better job
of communicating some of
these ideas to young people.
- Yeah.
- It's funny.
'Cause I hear a lot about
young people waking up to it.
So that that's my own
sort of world there,
but of course the
counterbalance-
- And Tom has spent a career,
spent a career trying
to explain these ideas.
I mean, his best-selling book,
he's known a lot of people
for his writings on race,
but his best selling book
is "Basic Economics,"
which is essentially
an economics textbook
without any graphs
and equations in it.
And he takes great pride
in explaining economics
to non economist and everyday
people in plain English.
He thinks it's a very
important thing to do.
It's one of the things he
learned from Milton Friedman
who spent his career
after leaving academia
as a public intellectual
who spent a lot of time
explaining economics
to non intellectuals on
college campuses and elsewhere.
And so Tom has taken great pride
in doing that
throughout his career.
And, you know,
sometimes in the academy
that isn't exactly rewarded.
It's looked down on.
Why are you writing
about, you know,
for the general public
instead of for your peers.
But Tom thinks that
that is the proper role
of a public intellectual.
- Yeah, and look,
as we watch public
education kind of crumble,
it's like we need those voices
that are gonna be
willing to do it.
In knowing him, did
you ever get a sense?
You know, obviously he wrote
mostly and cared mostly
about economics, but there is
a lot of racial stuff there.
Do you think that that was
just a by-product of the fact
that he was black, so he kind
of was sort of pinned into it?
Or do you think he really
wanted to talk about that stuff?
I remember in our interview
trying to ask that question
in a way that didn't seem
pandering or something.
- No, he reluctantly came
to writing about race,
and that's one of the
more interesting aspects
to his background.
Tom could have spent his career
writing about his first
love, which was economics,
and the history of economics
and the history of ideas.
That is his specialty.
He was an expert on Marx.
He's an expert on the classical
liberals from, you know,
the Adam Smiths and John
Stuart Mills and so forth.
That was Tom's first love
writing about those guys.
And that's what he spent the
beginning of his career doing.
And he was good at it.
I mean, he won high
praise from his peers,
and he could have
stayed in that lane
and lived a very fruitful life
teaching and writing
about economics.
He turned to writing
about race, as he puts it,
out of a sense of duty.
He said, "Because there are
things that need to be said."
And the way he put it is,
"To many other people have the
good sense not to say them.
(laughing together)
But they need to be said,
and someone's gotta do it."
And that is why he turned
his attention to race.
And he had a pretty formative
experience, I think,
when he was at Cornell
in the late '60s
which is when the rioting
occurred on campus.
And he was there at the time.
He was professor of
economics at Cornell.
And I think that made
quite an impression on him,
on where things were
headed, not just on campus,
but off campus as well in
terms of race in this country.
And I think it led ultimately
to him leaving academia
and joining the
Hoover Institution,
which is a think
tank at Stanford,
and also led to him writing
more about racial issues,
which is something he
turned his attention to
in the '70s and '80s.
- Do you have a sense
of how he's feeling
about the state of
the world right now.
I know in the last year or so,
obviously, because of COVID,
he wasn't doing many interviews,
we tried to get up there,
and then we just
couldn't coordinate it
with so many things.
He's 91, is that right? 91?
- 90.
- He's 90.
So he's 90 years old.
- He'll be 91 this year in June.
- I mean, for 90,
he is unbelievably spry
and everything else,
but obviously isn't doing
as many appearances.
I think he was on,
I think he was on Mark
Levin's show not too long ago.
Do you get a sense of
where he's at sort of,
you know, in the
politics of the day?
- I don't have a good sense.
We've communicated
by email a few times
over the past six months or so,
but not a whole lot since COVID.
He did publish a book last year,
a brand new book,
on charter schools.
And he did some
interviews for that book.
So he's still working.
I mean, he retired his
column a few years ago,
but he's still writing books
or updating editions of
old books and so forth.
And I've seen him
in a few interviews.
You mentioned "The
Mark Levin Show."
He's done some
other shows as well.
And I've seen some
of those interviews,
but I don't get a
sense of where he is,
how he's thinking about
what's going on now.
I will say that his general,
his general default position
is extreme pessimism
(laughs) about the way
the world is headed.
So I doubt anything that's
happened in the past year or so
has changed that (laughs).
- Yeah, I have a bad feeling
you're right on that one.
How was it for you personally
to get to know one
of your heroes?
You know, they always say
don't meet you your heroes
'cause it's always
going to be a let down
one way or another.
How was the whole
experience for you?
- It was a pure joy
to spend several years
delving into the intellectual
life of Tom Sowell
and getting inside of his head,
reading, trying to read
everything he's ever written,
and he's writing so
much on so many issues.
And he's just so knowledgeable.
And, you know, he.
Several times I found myself
while trying to write the book,
trying to explain
something more clearly
than he had already explained
it in what he had written.
And it was,
I came across that
time and time again,
but it was a real,
real thrill to,
and I was very happy
that he allowed me
to do the book or gave
me the green light.
It's not an authorized
biography, by any sense.
He didn't get to see anything
that I'd written before
it was published,
but he did cooperate.
He did sit for several long
interviews over the years.
And I was just very,
very grateful for that.
It's something I'm glad I did.
I hope, you know,
at some point I think a real
serious scholar of economics
is gonna have to
delve into Tom's work
and really get into the weeds,
which is something a
little above my pay grade,
because I'm just a journalist,
but I hope I produce
something that's readable.
- (laughs) I have no
doubt that you have.
What about on the on
the personal side?
Because I think
sometimes, you know,
especially for younger people,
you see these clips on
YouTube of these people,
or you see them in
the box on Fox or CNN,
and you kind of almost don't
think they're real people.
Like they're just these
things that exist.
You know, they're almost
like cartoon characters
of themselves in a way.
What did you learn about
just the way he's wired
or his temperament
or just interesting
on the personal side?
'Cause I don't know that
people know much of anything.
- Yeah. I'll start with.
I use a story in the book to try
and explain Tom's personality.
And I use a joke
from an old movie.
There was an old
movie called "Sabrina"
starring Harrison
Ford that came out,
I think, in the '90s sometime.
And the love
interest in the movie
is Harrison Ford plays this
very curmudgeonly industrialist.
And the family has a
long time chauffeur.
And the daughter
of the chauffeur
falls for Harrison
Ford's character.
And she goes to her dad
one day, and she says,
"Dad what was Harrison Ford
like when he was younger?"
And her father looks at
her and says, "Shorter."
(laughing together)
- I think I got the idea here.
- And it's a way of
just saying Tom Sowell
has been Thom Sowell for a
very, very, very long time.
And if you go back and
read or talk to him
about, you know, arguments
he would have for people
when he was in grade
school or high school,
very much like the arguments
he has with people today.
He's someone who
has been, sort of,
ready for intellectual combat,
it seems like since
the day he was born.
He's a very serious person.
He doesn't suffer fools,
but he's also a very generous
person, a very kind person.
And I got that from a lot
of people I interviewed.
Tom would go to bat with them
when they came to
him with a problem
whether it was a colleague,
a student, someone like that,
Tom was willing to
go to bat for them.
And so that side of
him also came through,
but he's always
been a, you know,
a very intellectually
curious person
and someone who was pretty
confident of his abilities.
And, you know, he's
a former Marine,
which might surprise
a lot of people,
because he's also
a bit of a loner.
He's not much of a team player.
And I don't think those
attributes work very well
in the military (laughs).
- And I know for a fact.
- Somehow, he made it though.
- I know for a fact, he's
not much of a techie,
because we were trying to
get Skype on his computer
so we could do it during
COVID, but he didn't want it.
He didn't want to download it.
And then we were going to
literally deliver a computer
to his door that he would
have just had to open,
but a whole other situation.
You'll, you know,
one of the other-
- Yeah, he's not a people
person in that sense.
He's worked from home
for a long, a long time.
He has an office on
the Stanford campus,
but generally he would go in
just to do interviews
with people,
but mostly work from home, yeah.
- You know, it's so interesting
because right now
when we all talk
about the sort of
lack of discourse
and the lack of sort of
honest public debate,
and it was like for years,
he was debating all sorts
of people on "Firing Line,"
all these other shows and and
public events and all of that.
And I would guess that
if they're, you know,
I'm sure he loves the writing
that he's still doing,
but I'm guessing he misses
probably some level of that,
the public sparring
with some of the people.
- I guess so,
but, you know, like you
said, he's 90 years old.
He's been doing it
for a long time.
I think he said his piece
more than a few dozen times.
- He doesn't need
that last knockout?
He doesn't need that last round?
- Yeah, you know, I
remember asking him
after he retired the column.
We were having
dinner, and I said,
"Do you miss being able to
get things off your chest?"
And he said,
"No, there's nothing left
on my chest." (laughs)
I think he, you know,
Sowell put a lot of thought
and time into his work,
and that required, you
know, doing your homework
and staying up on current
events and so forth.
And I think not having
to do that anymore.
I mean, he mentioned right
before he retired his column,
or decided to retire it,
that he had gone on a
sort of a photo safari
with a group of friends.
He's an amateur photographer
and a very good one
and has been for a long time.
But he ended up a few buddies
went on a photo outing,
a multiple day one,
and they, you know,
they didn't have any access
to radio or TV for a few days.
And he recalled how pleasant
that experience was.
And, you know, he was
already well into his 80s.
And he said, "You know,
I think I'm ready to (laughs)
tune out of the day to day."
And so I think he's
probably enjoying it.
I mean, like I said, he's
still doing the books
and staying active
intellectually on that front,
but I don't think
he misses, probably,
turning out that column
or two every week.
- Yeah. You'll probably
appreciate this.
When we sat down at Stanford,
his guys said he's
got 45 minutes.
Like he doesn't want to
sit there for makeup.
It's like when he gets in,
sit down, start 45 minutes.
So I was very aware.
I did not want to take one
extra minute of his time.
And when we hit 45, I ended it,
and he looked at me the
second the camera went off,
and he goes, "Is that all?"
Like.
(laughs)
I think he said, "Is that all?
We just started," or
something to that effect.
And I thought, "Man, if
I would've known that,
I would've kept going,"
but I wanted to
be respectful of,
you know, that he's busy
and all of those things.
Well, listen, I am super psyched
obviously to watch the doc,
and I'm honored
to be part of it.
And I can't wait to
get the book as well.
Is there anything else that
you'd want people to know
before they partake in the
doc or pick up the book?
- No, I think you've covered it.
I think it,
I think both the book
and the documentary
is a nice introduction
to Thomas Sowell.
And then I hope people, I
hope I wet their appetite,
and they go read more of
them, because like I said,
and like you, like you said,
he's been right for a long time,
and his stuff is as relevant
today as it's ever been.
So we'll see what happens.
- Awesome.
Well, Jason, I'm glad
we finally got to talk,
and should we send
people to your Twitter?
Should we send them
to your Twitter?
- That's fine. You can
send people my Twitter.
- Is it Jason Riley?
No, there's a letter in there
somewhere, right? I don't.
- It's @JasonRileyWSJ.
- WSJ, that's it. Okay.
I knew it was in
there somewhere.
All right. Well, it was a
pleasure to have you on.
I can't wait to see the doc,
and I'll talk to you soon.
- Thank you.
Take care.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.